Transcriber: Habip Bahçecioğlu
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
Herkese iyi akşamlar.
Bu akşamki konuşmamızın konusu;
Bir ülke nasıl kalkınır?
Şimdi, soru büyük tabii ki ve kompleks
bir soru ama isterseniz bunu biraz
basitleştirerek başlayalım.
Çok basit bir örnekle düşünelim.
Diyelim ki dünyanın iki yerinde
birbirinden çok uzak iki yerde iki gemi
battı ve yüzer kişi o gemilerden, yüzer
kişi iki farklı adaya çıktı .
Bu ada çok verimli, yani doğal kaynakları
açısından ve orada tabii ki vahşi
hayvanlar da var, ürünler de.
Orada çeşitli yabani meyveler vesaire
de var ama hiçbir insan yok.
Şimdi bu 100 kişi oraya gittikleri
zaman kendilerine sıfırdan bir
medeniyet kuracaklar.
Şimdi iki tane ada var.
A Adası ve B Adası.
A Adasına gidenler, ilk gün tabii ki
şoku atlattıktan sonra,
birkaç meyve toplamaya çalışıyorlar
ve gece mağaraya oturuyorlar.
Kendilerini korunaklı bir yere çekebilmek
için ve oturup düşünmeye başlıyorlar.
A adasındakiler, bütün yüz kişiden
de fikir topluyor.
Yani orada işte bu işin,
marangozu da var, demir ustası da var,
balıkçısı da var ve onlardan fikir
toplayarak orada nasıl bir yaşam kurmaları
gerektiğini ve bu probleme
nasıl yaklaşmaları gerektiğini sorguluyor.
İkinci adadakilerdeyse tamamen
farklı bir bakış açısı var.
Şimdi ilk bakış ilk adada kiler, ertesi
gün tabii ki orada uyandıklarında, işte
marangoz olan oraya bir kapı yapıyor ya da
bir merdiven üretip ağaca çıkıp meyve
toplamayı beceriyorlar.
Ya da daha sonra demir ustası onlara bari
bazı kesici aletlerle de balık tutma ya da
hayvanlarla mücadeleyi sağlıyor.
Balıkçı balık tutuyor vesaire.
İkinci adadaki o 100 kişi ise, en önce
50′sini ″Sen anlamazsın″ diye kadınları
bir kenara oturtuyor.
Daha sonra su küçüğün, söz büyüğün
diyerek gençleri bir kenara oturtuyor.
Daha sonra ″Sen fakir bir anne babadan
geliyorsun, senin söz hakkın yok″ diyerek
onları kenara itiyor ve o yüz kişiden
sadece üç kişi kalıyor.Ve o üç kişi bütün
adanın ekonomik ihtiyaçlarını
gidermeye çalışıyorlar.
Şimdi soru şu; Bu iki ekonomide sizce
hangisi daha ileriye gidecek?
Hangisi daha fazla teknoloji
geliştirecek?
Kendi ilkel teknolojileri tabii ki ve
doğayla mücadeleyi hızlandıracak ve bir
şekilde kendilerini geliştirecekler.
Tabii ki A Adası.
Çünkü orada yüz kişinin ürettiği fikirler
varken, B adasında ise sadece 3 kişinin
ürettiği fikir var.
Dolayısıyla, ekonomiyi siz ne kadar daha
kapsayıcı yapabilirseniz, ne kadar daha
çok insandan fikir toplayıp, onların en
iyilerini yukarıya çıkmasını sağlarsanız
işte ekonomiler ancak bu şekilde
ilerler ve o şekilde büyürler.
Çünkü siz öncelikle bir şeyler
üretmeniz gerekir bir ekonomide.
Balık, elde tutamayacaksınız belki
ilkinde ama eğer uzmanına
bırakırsanız ve o balık tutmayı eğer diğer
insanlara üretirse ya da onun
teknolojilerini geliştirirse çok daha
sistematik olarak balık tutulur.
Ya da dediğim gibi vahşi hayvanlarla
mücadele edecekse, ona göre marangozun ve
demir ustasının geliştireceği
teknolojilerle siz mücadele edebilirsiniz.
Şimdi dediğim gibi gerçekten katma değer
yaratan bilmenin tek koşulu uzman
insanların kendilerini ifade edebilmeleri.
Bu şekilde arzı arttırabilirsiniz siz bir
ekonomide ve büyümeyi sağlayabilirsiniz.
Ama ekonomin iki tane ayağı var.Bir arz
ayağı var, bir de talep ayağı var.
Talebi ne yönetiyor?
İşte talebi para politikaları yönetiyor.
Yani şimdi burada, bu adada nasıl
bir para politikası olabilir ki?
Para nedir diye düşünürseniz problemi
kısaca şöyle özetleyeyim.
Şimdi 100 kişi var, 100 kişinin de
ürettiği bir şeyler var bu adada.
Dolayısıyla eğer para yoksa bu adada
herkesin değiş tokuş ile
ticaret yapması gerekiyor.
İşte birisinin elması var, birisinin
balığı var, işte armudu var ve ondan
sonra elma satan kişi balığın
fiyatını bilecek işte.
Bir elma yarım balığa denk geliyor, bir
elma, iki armuta denk geliyor vesaire..
bir elmanın diğer bütün 99 ürün cinsinden
fiyatının olması gerekiyor.
Zaten 100 tane ürün var.
Dolayısıyla siz böyle bir adada ticaret
yapabilmek için, 99 çarpı 100, 9 bin 900
tane fiyatı bilmeniz gerekiyor.
Eğer sadece değiş tokuş üzerine
iş yapacaksanız.
Ama insanoğlu tabii ki akıllı varlıklar.
Ne icat etmiş , parayı icat etmiş ,
nasıl yapmış bu işi?
Demiş ki; Adadaki biz bir kişiye bir
otorite vereceğiz ve o kişi gidecek,
defne ağaçlarından yapraklar toplayacak
ve üzerine imzasını atacak.
Ve bu şekilde piyasaya para dediğimiz
o defne yapraklarını verecek.
Eğer bin tane defne yaprağı varsa artık
bizim 9 bin 900 tane fiyatı aklımızda
tutmamıza gerek yok.
Çünkü çok zor.
Ben de tutamam, siz de tutamazsınız.
Ama 100 tane ürünün fiyatını
bilmemiz gerekiyor artık.
Çünkü neden ? Biz bir elmanın defne
yaprağı cinsinden fiyatını bileceğiz.
İşte bir balığın defne yaprağı
cinsinden fiyatını bileceğiz.
Ama şunu gözden kaçırmamamız gerekiyor.
Şimdi bu para toplam otorite dedi
ki işte ben bin tane defne
yaprağı verdim piyasaya.
Ertesi sabah uyandım.
Ben ekonomiyi canlandırmak,
büyütmek istiyorum.
Ne yapacağım? Bin defne yaprağı yerine iki
bin defne yaprağı vereceğim piyasaya dedi.
Böyle bir durumda ne olacak?
Ne kadar büyüdü bu ekonomi?
Bir günden ikinci güne.Sıfır.
Çünkü ürettiğimiz şeyler hep aynı şeyler.
Sadece bin tane defne yaprağı da olsa,
20 bin tane defne yaprağı da olsa bu
ekonomide bir herhangi bir büyüme olmadı.
Çünkü biz yeni bir şey üretmedik
Yeni bir katma değer üretmedik
Yani bu ekonominin büyüklüğü, ne kadar
balık üretildiği, ne kadar elma üretildiği
ile alakalı.
O yüzden de ekonomik büyüme tartışmalarına
geldiği zaman işte
kafamızın karışmaması gerekiyor.
Siz sadece piyasadaki para miktarını bin
defne yaprağından iki defne, iki bin
defne yaprağını çıkarırsanız orada tek
oluşacak şey ekonomik büyüme değil.
Orada tek oluşacak şey enflasyondur.
Yüzde 100 enflasyondur.
Yüzde 100 enflasyon olan bir
ülke biliyor musunuz?
Ama buradan çıkacak sonuç sadece budur.
Şimdi.
Dolayısıyla bizim yani en basit
tartışmalarda dahi artık
kayıp olmamamız gerekiyor.
Biz bunu 90'larda da kaybolduk, 90'ların
ortasında Çiller dönemini hatırlıyorsunuz.
Bugünlerde de aynı tartışmanın
ortasında kayboluyoruz.
Çünkü biz doğru şeyi tartışmıyoruz.
İstediğiniz kadar doları
ya da işte faizi tartışın.
Değer yaratmıyoruz.
Değer yaratmadığın sürece onlar şifahi
konuşmalar.Bizim tartışmamız
gereken şeyler:
Biz nasıl değer yaratabiliriz?
Biz nasıl teknoloji inovasyon
yaratabiliriz, arzı nasıl yaratabiliriz,
arzı nasıl tetikleyebiliriz bunu
tartışmamız gerekiyor.
O yüzden sizden ricam, dediğim gibi bu
konuşmadan sonra umarım bu geceki
konuşmadan sonra artık bu para
politikaları tartışmaları eğer varsa bir
yerlerde telefonu, televizyonu
kapatmanızı rica ediyorum.
Çünkü tek tartışmamız gereken şey bu
ülkeden nasıl değer yaratabiliriz?
Araştırma konularımız, araştırma
ekibinde yaptığımız araştırma
konularımızın tek konusu budur işte.
Bir ülke nasıl büyür ve şimdi sizi
Türkiye'nin biraz resmini çekmek
istiyorum asıl konuşmamız gereken
konular açısından.
Türkiye, bu dünyadaki ülkelerin işte kişi
başına düşen gelirleri cinsinden
sıralanmış durumları.
Türkiye'nin durumunu zaten biliyoruz.
Sonlardayız.
Peki madem az önceki ada örneğinden
verdiğim gibi, değeri inovasyon
yaratıyorsa, acaba biz inovasyon
yapmadığımız için mi büyümüyoruz ve
zenginleşemiyoruz.
Cevap evet.
Burada, yıllar içerisinde size kişi başına
düşen patent miktarını gösteren bu
inovasyonun bir göstergesi.
Başka göstergeler de olabilir ama
baktığınız gibi burada gördüğünüz gibi
kişi başına düşen patent sayısı açısından
Amerika’da yukarı gidiyor,
OECD ile aramızda çok çok uçurum var.
Türkiye’deki patent miktarı, inovasyon
miktarını arttıramıyoruz.
Soru, neden arttıramıyoruz sorusunu
sorarsak,
inovasyonun aslında iki tane ayağı vardır.
Bir tanesi firmaların yaptığı araştırma,
geliştirme, Ar-Ge harcamaları , diğeri de
üniversitelerden çıkan teknolojik,
üniversitelerden çıkan bilimsel yayın
sayısı .
Şimdi üstteki iki grafik soldaki
Türkiye'de Ar-Ge harcamaları gayri safi
milli hasılaya oranla, sağdaki de
Türkiye'deki kişi başına düşen bilimsel
yayın oranı.
İkisine baktığınız zaman da Türkiye çok
çok arkalarda.İnovasyon göstergelerinde
çok arkalardayız.
Peki, bu acaba devletin yeterince destek
vermediğinden mi kaynaklanıyor?
Yani acaba kamu yeterince firmalara
gidip Ar-Ge’ye destek mi vermiyor?
Acaba devlet gidip üniversitelere
yeterince para mı desteğinde bulunmuyor?
Aşağıdaki grafiklerde, özel sektör
Ar-Ge’sine kamu destek oranını gösteriyor.
Yani özel sektöre kamu ne kadar
destek veriyor ülkelerde.
Sağdaki de kamunun yükseköğrenim
harcamasını gösteriyor,
alttaki grafikler.İkisinde de
OECD’nin çok çok üstünde.
Yani konu para meselesi değil, ayrılan
kaynak meselesi değil.
Konu kaynağın nasıl kullanıldığı meselesi.
Tartışmamız gereken konu;
hadi biraz daha vergileri arttıralım,
biraz daha kaynak yaratalım değil.
Eldeki kaynakları nasıl daha etkin
kullanabiliriz, bunu tartışmamız, bunu
tartışmamız gerekiyor.
Şimdi, isterseniz biraz daha
şu işin temeline inelim.
Çünkü inovasyon dediğimiz, Ar-Ge
dediğimiz şey ne ki?
Yani bir sosis makinası değil bu.
Sonuçta laboratuvarlarda, ofislerde
insanlar oturuyorlar, mühendisler, bilim
insanları oturuyor ve düşünüyorlar.
Peki, bu inovasyonları üretenler kimler?
Bunu bir anlayalım istedik ve bunun
için de şöyle bir şey yaptık.
Sistematik bir veri tabanı olmadığı için
Amerikan Patent Enstitüsü'ne gittik ve
1836′dan beri verilmiş bütün patentleri
arşivlerinden aldık.
Harvard’dan Tom Nichols ve Princeton
Üniversitesinden Jhon Grece ile birlikte
dijitize ettik ve elimizde artık bu patent
verilerin dijital halleri var ve bu
patent verilerinde kimler üretmiş
onları, onları biliyoruz.
Örneğin; Thomas Edison var,
Melvin de Groot var.
Bu arada işte, her akşam kendimizi suçlu
hissettiren çikolatalı dondurmanın
mucididir kendisi.
Aynı zamanda Nikola Tesla var.
Yani, bütün bu insanlar sistematik olarak
bizim verilerimiz de var ve biz artık bu
insanların ne gibi sosyo ekonomik
durumlardan geldiklerini anlamaya
çalışıyoruz.
Ve başarılı ülkelerde gördüğümüz en önemli
şey, eğitim şart.Ama eğitimin de
nasıl eğitim olduğu da çok önemli.
Şimdi burada, özellikle Danimarka’da
yaptığımız bir araştırmadan bahsediyorum.
Eğitim durumlarına göre,
gruplarına göre insanların mucit olma
ihtimallerini gösteriyorum.
Ve gördüğünüz gibi ilkokul değil,
ortaokul, lise, üniversite bile değil,
doktora.
Doktora eğitimi, bir ülkenin
ürettiği inovasyon ve teknoloji için
çok çok önemli bir olgu.
Türkiye’de ne kadar tartışıyoruz
doktora programlarını?
Türkiye’de üniversiteleri tartışıyoruz
ama yanlış açıdan tartışıyoruz.
Yani eğer biz gerçekten büyümek istiyorsak
gerçekten bir refaha kavuşmak
istiyorsak, verilere bakmamız gerekiyor.
Peki Türkiye'deki yüksek lisans, doktora
mezunu nüfusa oranla dünyaya göre nasıl
diye baktığımız zaman burada bütün
ülkeleri görüyorsunuz.
Aşağı doğru bir düşüş var.
Düştükten sonra oradaki birkaç
ülkeden birisiyiz.
Yani, verilere sistematik baktığınız zaman
artık problemin kaynağının nerelerden
geldiğini yavaş yavaş görebiliyorsunuz.
Başka bir şey daha göstermek istiyorum.
Şimdi eğitim var, eğitim var.
Bu, Amerika’daki mezun olan öğrencilerin
tez verilerini araştırdık,
yani tezlerini aldık
Amerika’daki öğrencilerin ve hangi
konularda çalışıyorlarmış diye baktık
verilere.Ve burada gördüğünüz 1970′lerde,
kırmızı çizgiye dikkat etmenizi istiyorum.
1970′ler de bilgisayar mühendisliği
çok çok gerilerdeyken...
çünkü bilgisayar diye bir şey doğru dürüst
yokken, bugün o kırmızı çizgi
yukarı çıkmış ve bugün mezun olan
öğrencilerin tez yazdıkları en yoğun
ikinci alan olmuş.
Türkiye'de durum nasıl?
Şimdi size, Türkiye’de 2010 sonrasında
yazılan tezlerin, hangi
alanlarda olduğunu söyleyeceğim.
İşletme birinci, ziraat ikinci, tarih,
psikoloji, ekonomi, din, elektronik,
hukuk ve ondan sonra bilgisayar geliyor.
Şimdi bu kadar hızlı gelişen, bu
kadar bilgisayarın hayatımızda
artık olmazsa olmaz.
Artık üretim şekli değişti.
Bilgisayar yoksa, üretim yok.
Bu kadar hızlı gelişen bir
üretim sistemine biz ayak uyduramıyorsak,
zaten problem oradan kaynaklanacak.
Şimdi, biraz da üniversitelerimize
dönmek istiyorum.
Şimdi eğitim az önce söylediğim gibi
üniversitelere dönersek,
üniversitelerimiz zaman içerisinde nasıl
verimlilikleri değişmiş diye bakarsak, bu
grafik bize Türkiye'deki üniversitelerin
verimli nasıl değiştiğini gösteriyor.
Yukarıya doğru kişi başına düşen yayın
sayısı artarken, 2006'dan sonra tamamen
bir durgunluk başlıyor.
2006′dan sonra oldu Türkiye’de?
Bu yıl yıl Türkiye'de açılan
üniversiteleri gösteriyor her bir kutucuk.
Ve bugün Türkiye'de açık üniversitelerin
%50'den fazlası 2006'dan
sonra açılmış üniversiteler.
Peki bunlar nasıl üniversiteler
diye bakarsak,
yatay eksende ve dikey eksende
farklı farklı şekillerde,
üniversitelerin verimliliğini, akademik
verimliliğini gösteriyorum.
Sıfıra yakın olmak verimsiz demek.
Uçlara doğru hem yukarı hem sağa doğru,
uçlara doğru olmak verimli demek.
Şimdi, gri noktalar devlet üniversiteleri,
kırmızı noktalar vakıf
üniversiteleri, sarı noktalar ise
2006′dan sonra açılmış üniversiteler.
2006′dan sonra açılmış üniversiteler
nerede verimlilik açısından?
Grafik zaten konuşuyor benim bir
şey söylememe gerek yok.
Peki, biz bu kadar kaynakla insanları
eğitip bir yerlere getirdiğimiz zaman ve
onların bilimsel yayın teknolojiler
üretmesini beklediğimiz insanlar...
peki Türkiye’de verimlilikleri
nasıl değişiyor diye
zaman içerisinde bakarsak yatay eksende
bir akademisyen yaşını görüyorsunuz,
akademik yaşın.Dikey eksende ise
verimliliğini görüyorsunuz.
Ne görüyoruz burada?
Yardımcı doçentken ya da doktora öğretim
görevlisi iken verimliliği artıyor,
doçentken verimliliği duruyor,
profesör olduktan sonra
verimliliği aşağı iniyor.
Yani bizim en ihtiyacımız olduğu
döneminde, profesörleri demek ki
yeterince motive edemiyoruz
ya da kaynak veremiyoruz
bilemiyorum işte bunun araştırılması
gerekiyor.
Biz o insanları bir şekilde kaybediyoruz.
Tartışmamız gereken bu.
Onun haricinde az önceki adada söylediğim
gibi biz ya yüz kişiden fikir toplarız
ya da bazılarını böyle kenara iteriz,
toplumda çeşitli sebeplerden ötürü.
Kadınların iş gücüne katılım oranı
açısından OECD ülkeleri arasında
ne durumdayız?
Sonuncu durumdayız.
Onun haricinde çalıştırdığımız az
miktarda kadının peki işsizlik
oranı nedir?
Orada da OECD’nin en tepelerindeyiz.
Zaten az miktarda kadın insan
çalışıyor ve onlar da
çok büyük işsizlik yaşıyorlar.
Akademide durum nasıl?
Bu genel iş piyasamız daki
durumdan bahsediyorum.
Akademide durum nasıl?
Akademide durum şu şekilde:
Üniversite öğrencileri arasında, kadın
oranı %50 civarındayken, doktor araştırma
görevlilerinde aşağı inmeye başlıyor.
Öğretim görevlisi, doktor öğretim
görevlisi, doçent, profesör derken kadın
oranı yüzde 30′ların altına iniyor.
Sorgulamamız gereken sorular bunlar işte.
Nasıl daha katılımcı yapabiliriz?
Çünkü zeka ve yetenek zaten
az bulunur bir şey.
Ve dolayısıyla da elimizde bu kadar
imkanlarla yetiştirdiğimiz bu insanlarıda
kaybetmememiz gerekiyor.
Son olarak da söylemek istediğim şey tabii
ki de ülke içerisinde bir atılım
yapmamız gerekiyor.
Ülke içerisinde insanları belli bir
şekilde en iyi yeteneklerine göre
yukarıya doğru çıkarmamız gerekiyor
ama bir şey daha var.
Az önce ki ada örneğine dönersek, diyelim
ki adanın yanından bir balıkçı geçiyor ve
balıkçı diyor ki işte benim teknem de
bir kişilik yer var,
bir haftalığına birisi gelsin o adadan ve
ben o kişiyi bir hafta boyunca anlatayım
burada nasıl iş yapılır,
işte rüzgar nereden eser, nerden ne
toplamanız, ne yemeniz gerekir vesaire.
Bir hafta sonra geri gelsin o kişi.
Bu şekilde bir insan dışarıya gidip
teknolojinin zaten gelişmiş olduğu
yerlerde eğitim görmüşse ya da orada
çalışıyorsa onlardan da faydalanabiliriz.
Dünyada birçok Türkiye'den oraya gitmiş
insan var, yetişmiş insan var.
Onlardan faydalanalım.İllaki onların geri
gelmesine gerek yok ama onlar da bir
şekilde Türkiye'deki projelere dahil
olabilir, uzaktan destek verebilir.
Peki, dünyada ki Türkiye’den giden
akademisyenlerin durumu ne diye
sorduğunuz zaman tabii ki
bunun verisi yok.
Ama biz oturduk verileri işledik.
Yani milyonlarca yayın verisinden
makine öğrenmeleri vesaire...
sizi sıkmak istemiyorum.
Dünyada ki Türkiye kökenli insanların,
akademisyenlerin haritasını çıkardık ve
oradan birkaç bulgu göstermek istiyorum.
Bir, Türk araştırmacıların, Türkiye’den
olan araştırmacıların Türkiye’den gitme
olasılığı neymiş ?
En önce aşağıya doğru bir gitme var.
Ama dediğim gibi Türk Akademisi
için 2006 bir devrimdir.
Yani devrim dediğim 2006
bir kırılma noktasıdır.
2006′da gitme oranındaki azalış duruyor
ve 2015′ten sonra yurtdışına gitme
oranında çok ciddi bir artış başlıyor.
Peki az önceki o yaşam döngüsüne bakarsak,
akademisyenlerin, nasıllar diye
sorduğumuzda dörde böldük
veride ki akademisyenleri. Kariyerlerine
yurt dışında başlayıp yurt dışında
bitirenler, devam edenler, kariyerlerine
Türkiye'de başlayıp Türkiye'de bitirenler,
yurt içinde başlayıp yurt dışına taşınmış
ve dönmemiş , yurt dışına taşınmış ve
dönmüş.
Şimdi şu grafikte iki enteresan şey
göstermek istiyorum size.
Düz kırmızı çizgi,
yurt dışında başlayıp yurt dışında
bitirenler,
onlar en verimliler.
En verimsiz grupsa, kariyerlerine
Türkiye’de başlayıp,
Türkiye'de bitirmişler.
Asıl acı olansa, mavi düz çizgi.
Kariyerlerine Türkiye’de başlıyorlar
verimsiz bir şekilde,yurt dışına
gittiklerinde verimlilikleri yukarda,
Türkiye’ye döndükten sonra verimlilikleri
yine aşağıya gidiyor.
Aynı insanlar, Türkiye’ye döndükten
sonra verimlilikleri düşüyor.
Bu da sorgulamamız gereken bir şey.
Aynı insan niye bu verimlilik
farkını gösterir?
Son göstereceğim şeyde, yani beyin göçünü
acaba beyin gücünü çevirebilir miyiz?
Bu grafikte size, yurt dışına taşınmış bir
insanın verimliliğini gösteriyorum.
Sıfır noktası taşınma yılı.
Bir insan, Türkiye’den yurt dışına
taşınınca 10 yıl içerisinde verimliliği
yüzde 25 artıyor.
Peki, geride kalana ne oluyor?
Asıl sorulması gereken soru bu.
Çünkü giden gitmiş, tamam
verimliği artmış.
Peki, geride kalana ne oluyor?
Bu eş yazarı yurt dışına gitmiş
insanın verimliliği.
Eğer irtibat halinde kalırlarsa, eğer
irtibat halinde kalırlarsa, yurt dışına
benim eş yazarım giderse ben Türkiye’de
kalırsam, benim de verimliliğim
yüzde 15 yukarı gidiyor.
Gidenin yüzde 25, benimki yüzde 15.
Peki irtibat halinde kalmazsak ne oluyor?
Hiçbir şey olmuyor bana.
Yani giden gittiği ile kalıyor, irtibatta
kalmazsak işte onlara böyle arkamızı
dönersek yurt dışındakilere, yurt
içindekiler de onlardan faydalanamıyor
ve hiçbir şey değişmiyor.
Dolayısıyla, umarım burada
tartıştıklarımız,
hem adalarda hem yarım adalarda,
politika yapanlara ilham verir.
Çok teşekkürler beni dinlediğiniz için.
Sağ olun.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)